- [Voiceover] The three Serra sculptures
in this gallery were conceived
and built for this room.
They were brought in
through a 40 foot door
that open onto the empty
lot next to the museum.
Each weights between 100 and 200 tons.
This one called "Band"
snakes horizontally for more than 70 feet.
- [Voiceover] This piece
unfolds its curvature
in a new template.
It has nothing to do
with any of the pieces
that have come before.
It's totally different vocabulary.
What I'd like you to do
is walk the entire piece.
You can walk inside and
outside continuously
if you'd like and never stop.
- [Voiceover] There are four volumes.
They move in and out, and
the piece moves in and out.
There's a shift between inside and outside
that seems continuous.
There are some spaces when you go into,
you think you've been in before,
but you realize you haven't.
You sense that they're similar,
but they're all dissimilar.
It's difficult to one
space from the other.
The entire sheet of steel,
as it ungulates though the
space changes continuously,
and its interior exterior
is continually exchanging.
- [Voiceover] Serra
says that the sculpture
creates new spaces within
the architecture of the room.
- [Voiceover] Look, if
this room were empty
it's like a field of space
bounded by these walls.
Then, when you walk
into a piece like this,
you're just dealing with
the sculpture volume,
not the volume of the
architecture of this room.
- [Voiceover] Serra worked out "Band"
in a series of inch to a
foot scale lead models.
- [Voiceover] I built "Band" in models for
about three years, and then
I built it in steel mill,
and then I went to look at it.
It was definitely a new experience,
and I didn't know what to make
of it for a couple of days.
It wasn't a questions of quality.
I didn't understand the space
of it. That surprised me.
- [Voiceover] Finally,
Serra felt that he had
a grasp of this sculpture,
and it's newly created form.
- [Voiceover] Thought it was
better than I thought it was.
I've been looking at 40 years of work.
You make distentions, and I think this is
as interesting as
anything else in the show.
- [Voiceover] Serra was asked if "Band"
would lead him in new directions.
- [Voiceover] I think it
all ready has, you know.